let's bring in Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire and
host with the Ben Shapiro show podcast
which I listen to every day Ben I want
to talk to you about this bill that the
President signed today but just before
the show started the Congressional
Budget Office put out this number they
are estimating a 12% drop in GDP for
this quarter 40 percent annualized and
federal debt to exceed GDP by the end of
the year and I know these are things you
think about a lot and maybe get your
take on the president signing this bill
but what happens on the other end of it
I mean that is the big question because
the underlying market fundamentals have
changed I mean the fact is that you can
tell people that they ought to stop
being in lockdown and it's still there
consumer behavior is going to change
fairly radically I think it's going to
be a while before we have a therapeutic
treatment that lowers the risk of this
thing if you're above the age of 60 if
you have pre-existing conditions that
describes a large percentage of the
population you're just not going to be
eating in a restaurant right next to
somebody for a long time you're not
gonna be going to a sporting event for a
long time
you're probably not going to be in a
retail establishment that's highly
crowded for a very long time and that
means that actually it's more important
not less important to get people back to
work so that we can see how the markets
play all of this out so we can see which
areas of the economy are going to grow
in sort of the new demand world and
people can move from jobs that no longer
existed jobs that will exist because the
economy will move in a different
direction it's just this is this is a
sudden shock it's gonna take a while for
the economy to recover it's not gonna be
a v-shaped recovery what do you think
about the tension between the desire to
reopen and then sort the on the other
side of it some people including the
media looking out at them and saying
it's too soon don't be foolish and
you're having this real almost a
cultural divide well I think that a
large part of what's happening here is
that Americans do understand that or
they should understand that there is no
situation which everybody is absolutely
safe where the threat comes to an end
where people go back to work and now
they can go without masks without social
distancing and the risk level is what it
was before any of this happen and I
think that that needs to be constantly
reinforced I also think that it's
important for politicians not to play
the the ridiculous game where they
suggest that if only we save a single
life than any policy is justified that's
the last refuge of the political
scoundrel policymaking is always about
when
competing values in weighing exactly the
cost to not only human liberty but to
human prosperity the number of lives
ruined not just the number of lives lost
what it looks like when you have 30
million people suddenly out of work
these are serious concerns and only
unserious people suggest that any policy
that is going to be taken is not going
to have costs and risks single factor
analysis here is the enemy of good sense
and that's why Andrew Cuomo is going to
end up opening up parts of New York
understanding that the risk still exists
for a lot of people and that's just
going to happen the same thing will
happen in Illinois the same thing will
happen in California the question is how
these governor's assess that risk and
exactly what the current lockdown
measures are designed to do I think that
very often the media do a poor job
explaining when they said flatten the
curve that was designed to prevent the
capacity of the healthcare system from
being exceeded it was not designed to
prevent everybody from getting this in
the first place that just is not going
to happen the the testing regimens the
people are talking about those are
designed to identify hot spots to
prevent spikes that again prevent the
healthcare system from being overwhelmed
they are not designed to prevent huge
numbers of people from getting this over
a long period of time understanding that
allows people to be more sane in their
risk assessment and to be more rational
about what exactly society is going to
look like coming out of this because I
think a too rosy an optimistic picture
of how safe we're gonna be when this
ends is a danger and I think similarly a
too pessimistic version of what this
looks like is also going to be a danger
there's also this problem of that if you
reopen and people are so expected to go
back to work but the childcare centers
and the schools are still closed how our
parents supposed to make those decisions
give you the last word yeah I mean
that's exactly right and again I think
that in the end we live in a republic
individual citizens are gonna have to
make decisions that don't threaten other
people but that allow them to live their
lives in a way that they feel
comfortable with and that risk
assessment is going to vary based on
person in a free country we're all going
to have to do that and to pretend
otherwise is simply just political lying
ben shapiro thank you say hello to your
family and shabbat shalom we'll see you
hey thanks so much again thank you